okay let's go next to um
where are we gonna go next let's go to
where are we going let's go to chris
from massachusetts who i believe is
already unmuted because they're a
moderator chris from massachusetts
you're on the air
hey david hello
hey so uh um i posted this
just kind of um
posted in the pack pals channel was
hoping to get some
get your thoughts on this what do you
think about
the
democratic party
uh it really started to embrace well i'm
not saying that they're doing this but i
think it would be a good strategy of
embracing the politics and the policies
of people like katie porter
rather than
the squad
there seems to be
a
uh cultural difference
but i don't know i always say there's a
difference in how
katie porter and members of the squad
approach some of these cultural issues
that are important yes um
but they also katie porter does a really
good job of
you know holding
people accountable especially in these
interviews that we've seen go viral uh
100 listen i think that there's two
different things going on here you've
correctly identified
that
culturally katie porter has a different
uh tone and approach
to issues than the squad and for me as
an individual
uh i tend to like katie porter's
approach a lot i didn't like it a lot
but i think there's a more important
piece
it has to be said
katie porter's much more knowledgeable
on a lot of these issues than the squad
types and i i'm not saying it
pejoratively i'm just saying katie
porter
has more experience particularly in the
space of finance and economics
and she's more knowledgeable and so what
i like the most about the katie porter
approach it's less cultural for me
it's more about
she's just so knowledgeable that you get
the sense that she's not only crafted a
series of questions that will look a
certain way
she understands the issues
in detail that are underlying all of
those questions and and i love the katie
porter approach i think your idea is
great
yeah and if you look i mean she
you know
was one of the few
um freshmen uh congress people to flip
or a historically red district yes and
that seems like
you know when you look at the fact that
the younger people that tend to support
you know the squad types the most they
don't show up and vote
so
the democrats are kind of stuck with
trying to
try to influence as much of the
independents to come out and vote from
the as they possibly can yeah and i
think and these cultural issues turn off
those independent types but katie porter
especially with her background in
education she has like this really
i mean she's so skilled at pointing out
exactly how people's pockets are getting
picked yeah by
you know banks
you know uh so a lot of these you know
property issues she was gonna i mean she
was going to be uh i think like a
housing advisor for elizabeth warren
um and like you said she's so
knowledgeable on these issues and she is
just able to really communicate to the
people like this is how you are getting
worked over by the people in power there
is no question about it that really kind
of uh
resonates with with
across the spectrum and how she was able
to flip a district so i i think that you
know
really the energy should
aoc is extremely popular ilhan omar also
popular you know and they have their
their place but i think like i think you
know
if we're going to put
as the reason we're going to put our
resources into the place where it's
going to have the most impact it's
getting behind people like katie porter
i agree i think in the context of the
conversation about 2024 nominees i don't
know that katie porter is is an
appealing nominee to a lot of people but
that's a different question and i think
everything you've pointed out is
absolutely true
all right thanks david all right thank
you so much for the call uh very very a
very good point
if you or someone you know is into
science astronomy space this is for you
our sponsor under lucky stars creates
beautiful personalized star maps
showing the unique position of the stars
in the sky
at the place and time chosen by you
under lucky stars is a great way to
remember an important moment someone's
birthday wedding day your engagement you
give them a time and a location that you
want to commemorate they show you
exactly how the stars and constellations
looked
in a spectacular super high quality
print it's a completely personalized
gift experience you can customize it
into a ton of designs you can read on
their website how all the star maps are
scientifically accurate
this is the one i got showing the time
of my birth in buenos aires argentina
the quality of the material and the
print they're fantastic i was really
impressed and i love that they support
the international dark sky association
to fight against light pollution under
lucky stars is perfect for valentine's
day and right now they're giving my
viewers ten percent off when you click
the link below and enter the code d
pacman